qu'il s'agisse de 90 minutes enquête
enquête exclusive ou encore enquête sous
haute tension les reportages en
immersion sur la police n'en finissent
pas de fasciner les français crs au
coeur du danger 24 heures avec les
gendarmes de la route ou autres
immersion dans les brigades spéciales
autant de titres et de programmes qui
bat des records il faut dire que pour
plaire aux téléspectateurs les
réalisateurs de ces formats ne lésine
pas sur le caractère sensationnaliste
des actions policières sévit au visage
flouté musique dramatique caméra cachée
autant de procédés immersif qui font
monter la tension alors on l'extrait
sans oublier la voix off légendaire qui
n'hésite pas à ajouter un côté
dramatique à la moindre situation davis
veut mettre la main au plus vite sur un
suspect dangereux
l'homme est déjà connu pour de nombreux
faits de violence sous la menace d'une
arme
des reportages parfois critiqués pour
leur prise de parti caricatural et
l'aspect théâtral de la mise en scène
était retenu risa dépôts en règle
c'est toujours pareil et ben non
monsieur les pas votre nom comptage
s'est cru bien pourquoi ce 12 heures par
jour
alors selon vous les émissions sur la
police sont elles trop caricatural
rapidement parce que figurez-vous qu'en
données si le policier fait semblant ici
les dents l'acting devant les caméras
déjà pour moi ce serait improbable
ici les professionnels et il fait ce
qu'il a à faire et comme justement ce
genre de programme ils veulent des
choses sensationnelles et ben ils sont
servis on voit vraiment ce qui se passe
donc non pour moi c'est pas si mal
bouffe c'est vrai dans l'épisode
les gendarmes sont obligés d'intervenir
car plusieurs vacanciers ont repéré un
exhibitionniste alors ils doivent bon on
va pas la montrer ça là moi je dis oui
et non oui pour quelles raisons oui dans
l'écriture du reportage parce que dans
l'écriture du reportage il faut de la
caméra embarquée il faut du suspense il
faut une voix off qui nous qui nous fait
trembler même si leur jeu est minimale
il faut bien en revanche ou non parce
que il nous montre nous montre quand
même un visage qui est celui de la
police donc un visage humain des gens
qui parfois se trompent
des policiers qui sont dépassés par toi
par les événements donc voilà il ya
l'excellence et la réalité maison alors
on a des petites images à la police
après que le travail la vie de rené
également et de bernard montiel et de
tout le monde d'ailleurs puisque vous
êtes tous intéressants enfin à des
degrés différents
est-ce que vous sélectionnez des images
bien sûr qu'on a vu dans ces repas
relève par exemple vous rappeler la
vidéo du policier qui se trompe de
maisons à la regarder passer des choses
retour devant la maison où serait
retranché un forcené armé puis vous
jouer n'importe où
après
[Musique]
finalement grecs décident d'utiliser une
technique basique sonné à la porte à
quelqu'un c'est mon club à piéger un
avis non pas du tout c'est comment son
prénom
ah non c'est pas si j'écoutais pas vu
non excusez-nous oui bon pour ces cui
vous je trouve que les connais genre
d'émission beaucoup plus importante est
beaucoup plus risqué parce que là avait
les caméras n'ai jamais compris comment
on pouvait la police ait voulu accepter
que les mains derrière la caméra on est
beaucoup trop les policiers qui mettent
ici
embarqué dans leur mission générale et a
marqué dans l'émission mais le plus gros
de cavale puisque te dire la caméra elle
et cassis il a fait moins j'avais mon
père qui était rare paulissen ah oui et
je te garantis que tu quand je regarde
ces émissions je me dis de se retourner
l'atome à jean mi
ben non je trouve pas on peut je ne sais
jamais si jamais critique vis-à-vis des
policiers ça montre contraire la dureté
du métier là de la variété des
situations le fils soient toujours
obligé d'être sur le king et
d'approvisionnement fonction des nerfs
numérique surface 2 moi je trouve ça les
met à l'honneur après c'est ce qu'on
appelait la télé gyrophare dans les
années 80 ça mais ça fait toujours
plaisir et nichane de grades de caresser
la police dans ce sens du poil mais
poussée des émissions qui sort gallo qui
dommages à la williams a baby zen et des
bises et monsieur before and cochonnet
des émules tuerie oui car est ce pas la
police dans le sens du poil justement
parce qu'on les voit des fois être un
peu dur avec les gens mais moi ce que
j'aime dans ses émissions
vêtements comme la retient la vérité
alors tu peux aussi c'est que
cette initiative a thing
ils sont les premiers la cible des
médias sur une soi-disant
[Musique]
non mercredi les chaînes qui est pas le
seul à aimer il commente la police et
qui a fait une connerie quoi et alors il
est ici ce talent et la rate et je vous
montre la vidéo préféré regarder ces les
policiers qui arrêtent un individu qui
lui demande ce qu'il pense du service
public c'est la cote
non bon joueur allez hop
les véhicules sont pas trop adapté mais
sinon ça va monsieur bah ils content
d'être avec nous visiblement je trouvais
donc voilà content du service public
monsieur seront d'excellents là vraiment
je compense les téléspectateurs de sa
regarder oui à ça quand tu % dont à 40 2
%